j'ouvre tout de suite notre second ébat
il concerne un phénomène exceptionnel en
passe de devenir
récurrent la sécheresse 35 départements
sont frappés aujourd'hui par des mesures
de restriction d'eau la liste devrait
s'allonger dans les prochaines semaines
avant d'affiner ce constat de voir
comment mieux partager cet or bleu je
vous propose un reportage pour illustrer
ces tensions de plus en plus fortes
parfois notamment autour des méga
bassines on a choisi un exemple dans les
Deux Sèvres à Mauzé sur le mignon
mathiasaraye c'est la première des 16
retenue de substitution ou méga Bassim
qui se déploieront ces prochaines années
dans le bassin de la Sèvres niortaise
dans le cadre d'une mission
d'information sur la gestion de l'eau
trois sénateurs ce sont déplacés dans
les Deux-Sèvres pour entendre toutes les
parties autour du sujet qui divise
demain après-demain on aura toujours
besoin de l'irrigation agricole mais il
faut que c'est irrigation agricole soit
faite de la meilleure qualité possible
en rendant les meilleurs services rendus
bien sûr à l'agriculture mais
exclusivement donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'on est là aujourd'hui ici 241
000 mètres cubes d'eau prélevé en
sous-sol cet hiver serviront à arroser
400 hectares répartis en 5 exploitations
là où certains crient à l'aberration
écologique Thierry Boudot président de
la coopérative de l'eau dans le
département répond qu'il faut distinguer
les projets en fait les territoires
hydrographiques sont très différents les
histoires politiques ou de construction
des territoires sont très différentes
donc là on est vraiment sur des notions
de territoire et c'est bien qu'une
mission parlementaire Vienne sur le
terrain sur un territoire parce que je
pense qu'on peut comprendre la gestion
de l'eau sur un territoire en ayant
compris le territoire dans les Deux
Sèvres peut-être plus qu'ailleurs la
thématique est inflammable après les
violences affrontements à sainte-solines
la préfète appel au calme
les mois qui ont suivi la signature
large du protocole il y a eu des menaces
il y a eu une monter de faire capoter un
projet moi ce que j'espère c'est un
apaisement sur ce projet ce que j'espère
c'est que il soit bien compris
que ce protocole est une innovation sur
bien des points au niveau de son
ambition agro-environnementale et des
moyens qui sont mobilisés pour les
atteindre pendant leur mission les
sénateurs sont également allés à la
rencontre des associations locales de
défense de l'environnement le collectif
bassine non merci et farouchement
opposés au prélèvement dans des nappes
phréatiques au niveau particulièrement
bas là on est dans une situation où les
nappes n'ont plus le temps de se
reconstituer ça fait deux fois ils m'ont
pas laissé finir mais la bassine de
Mozet là l'an dernier leur remplit à 80%
cette année il en remplit alors qu'il y
avait pas d'eau dans la rivière parce
que la préfète a fermé les yeux à
considérer qu'il y avait pas de problème
mais l'année prochaine ça va être encore
pire
et puis c'est la première et elle est le
plus en aval c'est à dire la partie la
plus basse quand les 5 autres seront
faites en amont de la rivière ils vont
se battre entre eux
la mission d'information va continuer
ses consultations encore quelques
semaines avant de rendre son rapport et
ses recommandations début juillet
comment faire pour éviter une guerre de
l’eau voilà le thème de notre débat je
vous présente mes invités Frédéric dans
et bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste écrivain spécialiste des
questions environnementales je cite ce
livre parce que vous en écrivez beaucoup
rencontre avec des écolos remarquables
parus aux éditions de Lachaud et Nestlé
Marie péter lati bonsoir bienvenue au de
vous retrouver sur ce plateau
hydrogéologue au bureau de recherche
géologique et minières Rémy bonsoir
à vous sénateur LR du cher président de
la mission d'information sur la gestion
durable de l'eau
urgence d'agir pour nos usages nos
territoires notre environnement on vient
de voir le reportage dans le Pas de de
cette mission dans les Deux-Sèvres on
était également duplex avec Nicolas
Garnier qui est directeur général de
l'association amorce bonsoir Monsieur
Garnier je signale que c'est peut-être
sur mon écran de contrôle mais vous êtes
vraiment dans la pénombre il faudrait
qu'on vous voit un peu mieux donc on va
essayer de régler ça dans les quelques
secondes qui qui précèdent votre premier
intervention et évidemment laetitia
cruppa est resté à mes côtés bonsoir
Laetitia peut-être un premier tour de
table en réaction à notre reportage sur
les bassines les retenus d'eau Frédéric
dans et est-ce que j'ai posé une
question vraiment basique est-ce que
c'est pas quand même le moyen le plus
efficace de retenir l'eau en cas de
pluie torrentiel on va en ce moment
qu'il y a des orages quasiment tous les
jours dans cette certaine région du Sud
si en théorie oui en pratique tout
dépend du terrain tout dépend du type de
nappe en dessous tout dépend de la météo
tout dépend de la prévisibilité de la
météo à venir et tout dépend des
cultures qu'on va en faire sur Sainte
Soline le projet tel qu'il avait été
conçu validé d'une certaine façon par le
BRGM le projet tu es loin d'être stupide
d'autant plus qu'il profitait d'une
nappe libre qui juge sous la surface et
qui en quelques heures passe de l'état
sec à l'étage des Bordes et donc il
suffisait en gros de mettre un tuyau
pour remplir une bassine donc en cela
c'était pas stupide sauf que et le BRGM
la reconnu le bergère répondant à la
question qui lui avait été posée avec le
Syndicat des irrigans n'a pas tenu
compte dans son rapport de l'évolution
du climat de l'évolution de la
pluviométrie et donc le projet se
retrouve en porte-à-faux c'est à dire il
était peut-être adapté jusqu'en 2020
mais semble-t-il qu'il ne le saurait pas
demain en tout état de cause il ne quand
on dirait-je le manichéisme qui s'est
appliqué sur lui n'avait pas de raison
et j'insiste là-dessus c'est bassine tel
qu'elles avaient été conçues n'allait
pas priver le milieu naturel des
quantités d'eau que j'entends de ce que
vous dites c'est que ça peut être
efficace en fonction des lieux en
fonction variable faut pas il on peut
pas être binaire sur
moi je reviens de l'éviter nous je
reviens d'un tournage mais on dit jamais
binaire et si je reviens d'un tournage
dans le Tarn ou j'ai pas rencontré et
c'est un endroit que je connais bien où
j'ai pas rencontré un agriculteur bio en
conservation des sols qui coachent
toutes les cases et qui dit j'ai pas
besoin d'eau il faudra mon un autre des
retenu colinéaires pour retenir ce que
vous dites les pluies de plus en plus
violentes qui s'abattent de plus en plus
sur le tas alors déjà j'ai appris
quelque chose merci et merci à vous
m'avezenattine nous le détailler une
bassine une méga bassine elle elle peut
être je sais pas c'est toujours le cas
en connexion avec les nappes phréatiques
c'est c'est le principe c'est parfois
c'est comment ça marche alors pas du
tout alors pas du tout ah bah c'est ce
que j'avais cru comprendre avec avec ce
business Frédéric denré il faut
distinguer la réserve de substitution
qu'on appelle bassine des retenues
colinéaires c'est encore autre chose on
peut mettre sur une colline une retenue
qui va s'alimenter soit avec du
ruissellement soit un barrage voilà ils
ont envie que le long d'un cours d'eau
et la réserve de substitution donc c'est
donc bien une bassine qui est
imperméable où on stocke l'eau lorsqu'on
en a le plus pour la réutiliser dans une
période où on a le moins mais alors
qu'est-ce qu'on avait pensé à Sainte
Soline ce entre la nappe la nappe en
dessous et la bassine la bassine est
remplie avec l'eau de la nappe prélevé
en période hivernale Frédéric la très
bien dit
hivernale cette nappe assez réactive
effectivement peut être
utilisé pour remplir cette bassine et
comme ça en été pour irriguer les
cultures on baisse la pression encore
faut-il qu'elle se remplissent en hiver
exactement voilà on doit rester question
et c'est ce qu'il y avait pas été prévu
dans le rapport du berger qui a pas été
modélisé
rémi.oro pardon vous étiez dans les
Deux-Sèvres évidemment avec cette
mission d'information sur la gestion de
l'eau que vous présidez
qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué là-bas
lorsqu'il va marquer d'abord c'est le la
colère des des agriculteurs et puis de
toutes les parties prenantes beaucoup de
troubles qui s'est créé par rapport à
ces réserves de substitution c'est le
vrai terme c'est ça c'est pas les
bassines ce sont des réserves de
substitution et c'est vrai que chaque
territoire est différent et en beau s'il
y a une nappe de Beauce qui est
enfermée qui n'a pas besoin de on n'a
pas besoin de bassines dans ce
territoire là dans mon département ce
sont des des petits cours d'eau des
passages d'eau donc on essaie de trouver
des solutions avec des retenues Colin on
commence à parler de réserve de
substitution et puis dans les
Deux-Sèvres effectivement on a rencontré
toutes les parties prenantes et
agriculteurs associés associations
environnementale hydrologue
les élus la préfecture et on a senti
quand même un vrai malaise dans ce
département par rapport aux
affrontements qu'il y a eu très violents
au mois de mai et on ressent vraiment
quelque chose de très fort et moi ce qui
m'a vraiment beaucoup
frappé je vais vous le montrer tout de
suite ce sont ces fils de fer barbelés
alors je sais pas si on peut
rester comme ça ça marche très bien donc
ça ça protège
devant un terrain militaire on n'est pas
devant une frontière entre l'Ukraine et
la Russie on est en France
on est vraiment dans une situation tout
à fait inédite dans la mesure où on
observe actuellement des nouveaux qu'on
est censé observer des années sèches en
juillet ou en août que ce soit pour les
autres souterraines avec 14 ouvrages qui
sont sous le niveau de crise sur les 22
qu'on mesure et on constate la même
chose sur les cours d'eau puisque les
trois fleuves côtier ont des débits qui
correspondent à des débits de crise
d'une période estivale alors ce cette
réaction elle date du 9 mai à répéter
Natty donc ça concerne la pleine nuit
aussi est-ce que c'est la région la plus
la plus touchée aujourd'hui dans
laquelle la situation est la plus grave
malheureusement c'est pas la seule mais
effectivement dans le Roussillon les
nappes on observe des niveaux
historiquement bas en plus sur la nappe
superficielle et sur la nappe profonde
il faut savoir qu'il y en a profondes à
mettre beaucoup plus de temps à se
renouveler et
à ceci s'ajoutent le phénomène
d'intrusion saline en milieu côtier
c'est à dire une absur-exploitée va
attirer le biseau salin donc on a une
eau en quantité déficiente et en qualité
également on a aussi dans toute la pour
tous méditerranéen et sur des nappes de
la Côte d'Azur aussi des niveaux
historiquement bas et dans le dans le
déjeuner également donc on a vraiment
des zones sur le couloir Ronson aussi
des des niveaux des niveaux bas à très
bas actuellement on est environ à 66%
des nappes du territoire qui sont à des
niveaux bas à très bas et historiquement
voilà il y a ces trois zones qui sont
vraiment très impactés très touchés les
orages dont je parlais tout à l'heure
c'est vrai que dans certaines régions il
y a des orages quasiment tous les jours
depuis des semaines alors je sais bien
que c'est peut-être pas au meilleur
moment de la saison et ça va ça va pas
suffire mais quel effet ça peut avoir
dans des régions où les nappes
phréatiques sont aussi basses alors les
faits il est quand même bénéfique si
c'est pas torrentiel consacré pas des
inondations et des dégâts on est bien
d'accord encore une fois il va
réhumidifier un petit peu les sols je
parle sous couvert de Frédéric il va
apporter voilà un petit peu de cette
fraîcheur mais ça va pas être un effet
perplex quasiment tous les jours même si
c'est quasiment tous les jours à part
sur les nappes vraiment très très
superficielle et très réactif qui vont
pouvoir se recharger un petit peu on l'a
vu mais surtout dans le nord de la
France avec des pluies de printemps là
qui ont pu marquer dans ces zones là au
nord-est par exemple du bassin Artois
Picardie des remontées mais dans le sud
là on est dans des situations tellement
critiques que ça va juste retarder un
petit peu la vidange retarder les
prélèvements parce que la végétation
sera un petit peu plus humide et les
sols un peu plus humide mais ça va pas
être la solution miracle ça c'est sûr
alors on va commencer à séries un peu
les thématiques dans notre débat et en
consacrant maintenant un chapitre
spécifique même si on en parlait à
travers les retenues et les bassines aux
agriculteurs premier consommateurs de
ces chiffres du ministère de la
il y a un an on va montrer qu'on est
capable de baisser de 10 15% en un an
deux ans et pas en 7 ans donc c'est pour
ça qu'on a présenté plan mais qui est
très focalisé sur sur les sur les
collectivités par contre sur le monde
agricoles si vous me permettez moi je
pense qu'il y a un sujet mais que vous
voulez peut-être aborder plus tard c'est
le prix de l'eau prélevé par le monde
agricole
en fait faut savoir que la les on paye
tous des redevances de prélèvement de le
droit d'accès à l'eau que ce soit l'eau
des rivières ou le ou l'eau des nappes
phréatiques tous les préleveurs que vous
avez cités les pays mais il paye pas du
tout la même chose c'est-à-dire qu'un
mètre cube pour vous et moi pour se
brosser les dents on le paye à peu près
3 à 4 centimes le mètre cube vous me
direz c'est pas beaucoup mais ça
s'ajoute c'est une sorte de taxe qui va
servir à financer les agences de l'eau
et c'est très bien ces trois quatre
centimes et bien le monde agricole il
paye 10 fois moins et une centrale
nucléaire paye 50 fois moins en fait le
monde agricole ou ou l'énergie ou
l'industrie ont de l'eau quasiment
gratuite donc à partir du moment où vous
avez un bien quasiment gratuit comment
vous espérez des logiques de sobriété
donc nous on appelle un rééquilibrage y
a pas plus de raison que le mètre cube
qui servent à nous à nous doucher
vous et moi et une redevance 10 20 30 50
fois supérieur à l'eau qui sert à à
arroser les champs ou à faire
fonctionner une centrale nucléaire les 3
sont vitaux d'une certaine manière donc
on appelle un rééquilibrage qui au
passage permettrait de générer à peu
près 1 milliard de recettes dont on a
besoin pour faire des économies d'eau et
on en reparlera tout à l'heure pour
faire du ryude pour faire des économies
sur les réseaux etc on a on a
terriblement besoin de de moyens pour
faire le plan du gouvernement que
aujourd'hui est pas totalement financé
ok je reviendrai vers vous évidemment
pour détailler tout ça sauf que ce que
vous venez de dire sur le prix de l'eau
ça a fait réagir sur ce plateau
peut-être pour commencer Rémi Pointreau
faire payer l'eau finalement un juste
prix ou en tout cas plus cher aux
agriculteurs aux industriels qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez monsieur Garnier a
oublié de dire que quand vous ouvrez le
robinet vous avez de l'eau qui avait il
y a du fonctionnement il y a des
canalisations il y a derrière des pompes
qu'il faut faire tourner et quand vous
êtes agriculteur c'est la même chose
c'est l'agriculteur qui paye l'énergie
qui paye le fonctionnement et ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent de d'amener l'eau à
jusqu'au bout du champ il y a un coût
quand même très élevé donc
en proportion le l'agriculteur paye
aussi très cher le mètre cube d'eau au
final donc il faut quand même le
rappeler et puisque je vous l'ai dit
également c'est que les chiffres que
vous avez donné sont pas tout à fait du
ministère oui mais la réalité la réalité
est tout autre on a aujourd'hui 500
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau qui
tombe sur la France métropolitaine 200
milliards de mètres cubes d'eau parce
que faut relever relativiser tout cela
200 milliards de mètres cubes d'eau
utile pour l'ENA pour remplir dérivation
et à l'intérieur de cela 30 milliards de
mètres cubes qui sont consommés dont 6
milliards pour l'irrigation et à peu
près autant pour l'eau potable c'est à
peu près les chiffres bon mais vous
prenez dans l'eau potable et à 1
milliard de mètres cubes de qui sont
perdus dans les canalisations les fuites
donc ça retourne à la terre quand même
non parce que non non non
non il y a une grande partie qui
s'évapore parce que il faudrait des
fuites très importantes pour que ça
retourne à la nappe et quand on regarde
tout cela un milliard de mètres cubes
perdus ça représente 2000 réserves de
substitution de 500 000 mètres cubes
donc il faut relativiser
je suis d'accord avec vous je voudrais
le prix de l'eau le prix de l'eau frérot
dans votre avis je redonnerai la parole
à Nicolas garni je t'appelle fuite aussi
qu'il faut payer j'entends ça
4 € le mètre cube en moyenne en France
effectivement vos chiffres chers Thomas
57 % de consommation sur les
prélèvements ces 57 % d'eau consommée
par l'agriculture sur 9 % qu'elle va
chercher dans le milieu naturel c'est 57
% de 9 % en fait ça fait pas compris en
fait quand on prélève 100 litres en
France il y a 9 litres qui sont prélevés
pour l'agriculture d'accordé et sur ces
9 litres il y en a la moitié qui sont
réellement consommés le reste regagne le
milieu naturel c'est toute la différence
entre consommation et prélèvement qui
est qui est assez subtil bon peu importe
quatre rôles mètre cube est-ce que on
augmente le prix de l'eau payé par les
agriculteurs on améliorait les choses je
suis pas convaincu du tout le problème
des agences de l'eau c'est que elle
manque d'argent elle manque d'argent
parce qu'on les oblige à financer
l'Office français de la biodiversité
elle manque d'argent parce qu'on les
oblige alors ça vient ça ça a été enfin
voté par le Sénat on les obligeait juste
qu'il y a peu de temps à ne pas dépenser
plus à ne pas dépenser au ce qu'on
appelle le plafond mordant les les
agences de l'eau manque de ressources
également parce que à mesure que la
qualité de l'eau que la qualité de l'eau
s'améliore à mesure que la consommation
baisse grâce aux politiques qui nous
incitent à baisser notre consommation et
bien les taxes prélevées par les agences
de l'eau baisse alors on peut augmenter
le tarif de l'eau payé par les
agriculteurs mais ça va pas changer
grand chose et effectivement le coût de
l'irrigation le coût de l'électricité
dans l'irrigation augmenter de 60%
depuis l'accord Nicolas Garnier vous
lirez agir je vous donne la parole oui
merci parce qu'effectivement je pense
que j'ai été mal compris au mal
interprété mais d'abord effectivement ça
a été dit les chiffres que je donne sont
bien sur les redevances et pas sur le
service public de l'eau je je je je
corrige ce qu'a dit Monsieur sénateur je
vous parlais bien que de la redevance de
prélèvement le coût du service
c'est-à-dire les tuyaux les pompiers etc
est à l'extérieur est-ce que c'est
Frédéric a présenté comme les quatre les
quatre rôles mètres cubes en plus de
cette redevance donc je parle bien que
de l'accès à l'eau effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est inéquitable et là pour
une fois on va être en désaccord ou en
tout cas j'espère qu'on sera bientôt
avec Frédéric c'est que ce cette
financement générer à peu près un
milliard d'euros c'est à dire augmenter
de 50% les capacités des agences de
l'eau si on arrivait à et pas seulement
sur le monde agricole mais aussi sur le
monde de l'énergie les centrales
nucléaires dont on parle beaucoup et on
nous annonce qu'il va y en avoir le
double aujourd'hui ne paye quasiment pas
leur accès à l'eau et là par contre je
reviens dessus je suis d'accord avec
monsieur le sénateur attention à pas
tout limiter à la question de la
consommation parce que le vrai sujet
c'est le prélèvement c'est-à-dire que si
il y a pas de l'eau pour tout le monde
vous pouvez la redonner l'eau un peu
plus tard ce que ne fait pas le monde
agricole ou ce que fait pas un service
public d’eau et bien vous n'avez pas
d'eau donc il faut vraiment aborder le
sujet par la question des prélèvements
plutôt 31 milliards de mètres cubes et
effectivement 50% c'est de l'industrie
nucléaire principalement l'idée quand
même de rééquilibrer je vois vraiment
pas pourquoi le mec cube d'eau pour se
brosser les dents aurait une redevance
d'accès à l'eau de 50 fois supérieure à
l'accès à l'eau d'une centrale nucléaire
les arguments des uns et les autres
là-dessus je j'avance un peu je reprends
la main Marie péter la team pourquoi les
c'est important de de financer ces
agences de l'eau est-ce que on dit
comment éviter la guerre de l'eau est-ce
que elles ont elles sont en charge ça
qui finalement
est au milieu de ce de ce bagarre entre
les différents usagers de l'eau
aujourd'hui oui enfin les agences elles
financent tout un tas de choses
la rénovation des stations d'épuration
effectivement la réduction des fuites
etc etc donc elles ont des grands
programmes les agences qui définissent
un certain nombre d'objectifs
d'orientation pour arriver à une gestion
intégrée de la ressource en eau alors
qui qui tranche la gouvernance de l'eau
en France elle est assez complexe c'est
une gestion décentralisée mais elle
marche effectivement parce que ça marche
trop plus proche des territoires voilà
donc gardons ça gardons ça gardons ça
c'est une vraie démocratie de l'eau via
les commissions locales de l'eau qui
gèrent l'eau parmi tous les usagers des
représentants de chaque usager face aux
représentants de l'État à l'échelle
d'une rivière par exemple et souvent
assister à une réunion c'est assez
amusant les gens parlent dôme en fait
ils parlent d'eux ils parlent de leur
territoire de leur métier de leur
territoire enfin voilà c'est un bien
commun c'est dans la loi sur l'eau c'est
un bien commun que l'on gère ensemble et
globalement ça se passe bien les
conflits sur l'eau jusqu'à présent ont
été aplanis pourvu que ça dure même si
il y a un problème de complexité de la
gouvernance et d'argent sur la politique
alors allez-y le vrai enjeu c'est de
multiplier ses clés ce qu'on appelle les
commissions de locale de l'eau parce
qu'il y en a pas partout les sages qui
doivent mettre en application les sages
et schémadies du monde gestion de l'eau
voilà
d'aménagement et de gestion de l'eau et
il y en a pas partout donc
à mettre en place les sages j'ai appris
encore d'autres acronymes grâce à vous
ok
allez je reprends la main parce que le
temps a filé à toute vitesse ça prouve
que le débat était passionnant il nous
reste beaucoup d'éléments à avoir et je
commence avec vous Laetitia puisque vous
vouliez revenir en continu de parler des
agriculteurs sur une proposition de loi
adoptée au Sénat mois dernier cas
déclenché une je clique sur la supposée
déconnexion des politiques sur ces
enjeux d'urgence climatique ah oui on va
parler du Sénat aussi pourquoi et
c'était le 16 mai exactement le Sénat
d'hôtel à proposition de loi pour un
choc de compétitivité on va faire en
faveur de la ferme France
proposition
transpartisane parce qu'elle était
portée par des députés LR par des
députés centristes et des sénateurs
pardon socialiste et pourquoi ça fait
réagir et plutôt grincer les dents aussi
quand même parce que cette proposition
de loi était largement favorable dit
c'est des tracteurs à la FNSEA et au
lobby des agriculteurs puisqu'une série
de mesures levée énormément de
contraintes qui sont entrées pourtant
dans les mœurs et dans les usages par
exemple le texte préconisait un retour
des épandages aériens l'usage de
certains pesticides la sanctuarisation
on le coup des méga bassines ou alors
carrément la pour le ministère de
l'Agriculture de contourner les
décisions de l'âme 16 vous savez c'est
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation de l'environnement et
du travail et tout ça Thomas sous le
prétexte de rendre plus compétitive la
ferme France bref l'agriculture
française bon ce qui est un bon objectif
la rendre plus compétitive alors
pourquoi c'est quoi les arguments de
ceux qui disent cette hors sol mais ils
ont dit tous les détracteurs encore une
fois vous avez dû les entendre comme moi
ils ont dit que c'était un chèque en
blanc fait à l'agriculture intensive aux
dépens de toutes les salaires de ces
dernières années et que cette
déconnexion
supposée à les creuser encore une fois
la distance entre les Français et les
représentants politiques il me semble
que les sénateurs ne sont pas les seuls
Thomas il y a une certaine déconnexion
sur ce sujet politique dans son ensemble
vous semble concernés
vous allez répondre et pendant la
campagne présidentielle c'est pas bien
Roussel qui avait trouvé cette image
génial du steak le steak le barbecue ce
qui mange la bonne viande et puis alors
tout le monde ensuite à embrayer sur ce
sujet qui nous facilité extrême pourquoi
parce que c'est de la démagogie pure
alors on séduit les Français qui sont
censés j'ai bien censé être réputé aimer
la bonne chaîne et donc on essaye de les
mettre de se les mettre de son côté
il y a quoi quelques semaines on va dire
un journal Marbella qui a remis encore
une fois dans une interview à France
Inter cette opposition entre les affines
sonados du barbecue et les mangeurs de
quinoa bon je pense
qu'en faisant de la com au gros rouge
qui tâche les politiques se trompent ils
passent complètement à côté d'une
réalité alimentaire que tout le monde à
laquelle tout le monde fait face écouter
Thomas on nous dit à longueur de temps
qu'il faut cesser de manger de la viande
en tout cas moi en manger
manger pourquoi parce que c'est
contraire à en tout cas le cercle
vertueux de l'environnement et aussi
pour notre santé pour notre santé donc
comment les Français peuvent-ils
comprendre ces injonctions à aider
l'agriculture intensive à consommer de
la viande alors qu'on leur dit au bout
de course bah non il faut pas il faut
quand même baisser votre consommation
quand on regarde les rapports de
Greenpeace par exemple et qu'on comprend
que la majorité des terres agricoles
servent à quoi à produire des céréales
pourquoi Thomas pour nourrir le bétail
à la fin quand même le français entend
oui mais manger moins de viande d'accord
bon on comprend l'absurdité de la
situation bon et ça nous ouvre ce débat
sur la viande merci beaucoup Laetitia
parce que c'est un vrai débat on l'a
déjà et on a fait un débat entier sur
sur la viande faut-il manger moins de
viande et ce qui est ressorti du débat
ce que j'avais retenu c'est que il
fallait continuer de manger de la viande
française produite dans de bonnes
conditions mais arrêtez d'importer de la
viande de l'une un peu partout votre
avis là-dessus
je suis tout à fait des accords avec
avec voisine de droite parce que oui non
mais vous faites oui mais bon je crois
qu'on est enfin vous êtes hors-sol quoi
je veux dire on a besoin d'une
agriculture indépendante aujourd'hui en
France
on perd des parts de marché parce qu'on
fait toujours de la surtransposition
européenne moi quand je vois
que les produits qui sont autorisés en
Allemagne ou en Espagne et que nous en
France on peut plus les utiliser qu'on
soit tous au même niveau
des produits qu'on ne peut qu'on pourra
plus faire c'est là qu'on voit que
l'équation électrique
je reprends la main excusez-moi parce
que je voudrais qu'on revienne sur l'eau
c'est le cœur de notre débat est sur la
viande puisque laetitia a ouvert la
question de la viande bon la viande
d'accord c'est lié oui mais peut-être
pas dans le sens que tu imagines ça
m'intéresse de vous entendre là-dessus
qu'est-ce qu'il faut mieux est-ce qu'il
faut mieux avoir en terme de retenue
d'eau il faut mieux avoir je veux dire
des champs de céréales ou euh des
prairies avec des avec des dans votre
question avec des bassines c'est la
prairie parce que la prairie est très
riche en matière organique donc elle est
très riche en tout petit trou dans
lesquels l'eau va pouvoir s'accumuler
accessoirement une pré c'est ce qui
c'est ce qui se fait de mieux en terme
de stockage annuel de carbone et si vous
voulez une prairie il faut des vaches et
si vous voulez des vaches et ben faut en
manger donc avoir cette réserve utile en
nous ce qu'on appelle l'eau verte
implique de conserver les prairies
implique d'avoir des milliers ouverts
implique de conserver l’élevage
qui sont contradictoires on mélange une
moyenne mondiale qui est tirée vers les
hauts par les élevages extra-intensifs
qui ont besoin d'eau d'irrigation ce qui
fait qu'on aboutit à 10 000 litres d'eau
en moyenne consommer en eau
d'irrigations pour avoir un kilo de bœuf
argentin ou californien mais en France
c'est si c'est 150 litres c'est un
maximum parce que la vache ne bénéficie
n'utilise que l'eau de pluie qui va
ensuite s'infiltrer dans les sols et si
vous allez me dire peut-être et si on
arrête l'élevage on arrête la prairie la
prairie se couvre d'arbre les arbres
sont des pompes à eau et vous aurez
moins d'eau en sortie et moins d'eau
dans le sol ok donc gardons de l'élevage
parce que quand il est fait par des
électeurs français il est moins intensif
que dans les deux les deux plus grands
pays les deux plus grands pays de
production ok j'entends cet argument
Marie Pétain a dit voulait intervenir
ici ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'il y a la notion d'empreintes haut
qui est en train d'émerger là dans les
discussions c'est-à-dire qui on doit
bénéficier d'un d'une traçabilité en
fait de chaque filière de production sur
sa consommation en eau comme on a une
empreinte carbone et pour pouvoir gérer
au plus proche des territoires voilà
parce qu'ils ont des besoins économiques
de développement voilà il faut nourrir
aussi la population faut toujours être
tout dans la mesure et pour ça il faut
des indicateurs donc cette empreinte
haut et les chercheurs travaillent
dessus d'ailleurs à définir ça emmènera
tout un tas de contrôle forcément comme
l'empreinte carbone voilà puisque ça
peut générer aussi économiquement
quelque chose
on peut pas ramener le fonctionnement de
l'écosystème uniquement cet indicateur à
quoi ça sert de passer du PIB au carbone
d'un indicateur mono-spécifique un autre
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
l'eau la biodiversité les sols allez on
parle des restrictions d'option 35
départements Français sont aujourd'hui
concernés par des mesures de restriction
d'eau pour les préfets la priorité c'est
de sécuriser évidemment
l'approvisionnement en eau potable un
exemple avec le préfet des Pyrénées
Orientales la sécurité des personnes
l'eau potable personne ne peut dire bah
non ça on met une croix dessus c'est
donc bien ça qu'il faut sécuriser donc
d'abord que chacun voit que c'est pas
chez les autres il faut faire des
efforts même si tout le monde doit en
faire mais c'est soi-même qu'on va faire
les efforts non dans son domaine qu'on
soit entreprise collectivités
agriculteurs particuliers
chacun est concerné par des efforts il y
a les mesures restrictives qui
s'appliquent mais il y a aussi le bon
sens du quotidien
et avec vous tome 3 nuit rebonsoir on va
donc lister les départements en
situation de sécheresse niveau de
gravité qu'est-ce que ça implique pour
cela
on va mises à jour par le gouvernement
et qui répertorie les arrêtés sécheresse
alors vous avez quatre niveaux d'alerte
du mois grave au plus grave alors vous
voyez sur notre carte vigilance en jaune
alerte en orange alerte renforcé en
rouge et crise en noir à chaque fois des
arrêtés préfectoraux sont pris et sachez
aussi que les mères peuvent prendre des
arrêtés encore plus restrictifs si le
juge nécessaire alors on commence par le
premier niveau jaune vigilance en
vigilance sécheresse alors dans ce cadre
là les particuliers les professionnels
sont simplement incités à économiser
l'eau on est simplement au stade de la
sensibilisation il n'y a pas de
restriction vous voyez que de très
nombreux départements sont aujourd'hui
concernés du Nord-Pas-de-Calais aux
Bouches-du-Rhône les Alpes de
Haute-Provence l'eau dans passant par
l'Yonne mais aussi par exemple des
départements peut-être que l'on attend
moins le Calvados la Loire-Atlantique on
en a compté avec nos petites mains 56
je dis tout deuxième niveau avec des
premières restrictions pour réduire les
prélèvements d'eau et voilà environ 35
départements sont touchés par des
restrictions et
en appartement en niveau d'alerte
souvent ce n'est pas tout le département
mais simplement des zones de plus
restreintes qui sont concernés dans le
département sont concernés par exemple
la Vendée le Var la Haute-Saône alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on y va
alerte et bien il faut réduire tous les
prélèvements les activités par exemple
en milieu aquatique sont interdites fini
le kayak finit le canoë et les
agriculteurs doivent réduire la
prélèvement mais de moins de 50% ou ne
pas arroser simplement trois jours par
semaine les particuliers eux doivent
aussi limiter l'usage de l'eau pour
limiter sa perte par évaporation donc la
rosace des pelouses des potagers est
interdit entre 10 11 heures et 18h ce
sont donc les heures les plus chaudes on
peut pas non plus laver sa voiture
soi-même mais chez un professionnel et
on n'a pas le droit de remplir sa
piscine ni de faire sa mise à niveau
troisième niveau l’alerte renforcée
voilà rouge c'est une partie du Sud qui
est concernée le gars l'Hérault mais on
a vu aussi par la Vienne l'Oise a l'air
renforcé ça veut dire que toutes les
restrictions du niveau précédent sont
renforcées par exemple les agriculteurs
doivent encore plus leur prélèvement de
plus de la moitié arroser moins de trois
jours et demi par semaine et le préfet
peut décider de l'interdiction totale de
l'arrosage des jardins ornementaux et
réduire ce lit des potagers entre 20h et
9h et on termine avec le quatrième
niveau qui est celui de la crise où là
on est dans une limitation drastique
voilà un niveau déclenché pour préserver
les usages vraiment prioritaires c'est à
dire la santé la sécurité civile l'eau
potable la salubrité vous le voyez il y
en a déjà des départements qui sont
concernés c'est le cas aujourd'hui des
Pyrénées-Orientales on a entendu tout à
l'heure le Préfailles pour cela il y a
l'interdiction par celle ou totale des
prélèvements pour l'agriculture arrosage
des espaces verts interdits nettoyage
des surfaces interdit mais qui dit
interdiction dit aussi dérogation Thomas
on se rappelle l'an dernier la polémique
qui avait été soulevée autour de
l'arrosage des golfes polémique qui
avait été soulevé par des élus de gauche
notamment des écologistes comme le maire
de Grenoble
Eric Piol car et bien voilà on le voit
le tweet qu'il avait écrit au mois
d'août dernier les Golf ont fait l'objet
d'un accord cadre qui est signé entre la
Fédération Française de Golf et le
ministère de la transition écologique un
accord qui prévoit que même en seuil de
crise les Golf peuvent continuer à être
arrosés la nuit sauf en cas de pénurie
d'eau potable bref l'herbe est plus
verte sur les greens d'à côté merci
beaucoup Tam traduis je vous propose de
d'accueillir une nouvelle invité qui est
avec nous en doutait en duplex jouer le
pullynx qui est délégué général de la
Fédération des professionnels de la
piscine le temps affilié je vais prendre
juste quelques minutes avec nous désolé
de vous avoir fait attendre les Français
champion d'Europe on a plus de 3
millions de piscines individuelles dans
dans notre pays
à quoi ça sert d'avoir une piscine si on
peut plus la remplir avec les arrêter
sécheresses comment vous réagissez à ça
alors d'abord une médecine ça conserve
l'eau pendant des années c'est à dire
que on va utiliser 39 mètres cubes au
premier remplissage et ensuite on va
recycler l'eau en permanence pendant 10
ans pendant 15 ans il y aura peut-être
besoin de faire certains un panneaux à
point d'eau si on n'a pas de couverture
mais si on a une couverture qui va
limiter de 90 % les vaporation
finalement un chiffre est important à
retenir c'est que
99,85% des usages de l'eau ne concerne
pas les piscines donc si on pense qu'on
va résoudre le problème de l'eau en
interdisant le remplissage des piscines
je pense qu'on se trompe totalement de
combat mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'il faut ça veut dire qu'il faut
apprendre à des usages de l'eau pardon
nous avons interrompu c'est moi c'est
moi c'est toujours compliqué quand on
est en duplex mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut apprendre quand on est propriétaire
ça concerne de plus en plus de Français
faut apprendre à bien utiliser sa
piscine c'est ce que vous dites
absolument on ne vit jamais une piscine
on n'a pas besoin de vider d'un tiers sa
piscine en hiver si on met une
couverture on limite de 90%
l'évaporation du bassin et son système
de filtration on doit le nettoyer que
juste quand c'est absolument nécessaire
et conserver une bonne qualité de l'eau
pendant toute l'année va permettre de ne
jamais vider son bassin il y a aucune
raison de vider un bassin s'il est
correctement entretenu ça c'est
important et c'est pour ça qu'on vient
d'éditer un flyer de conseil qui est en
sur notre site c'est gratuit pour
reconnaître les bons usages de l'eau en
matière de piscine privée familiale il y
a une affiche également qui sera chez
les professionnels de la piscine et on
fait signer à nos professionnels une
charte d'engagement des économies d'eau
pour que les professionnels proposent
systématiquement les bons équipements et
des livres systématiquement les bons
conseils à leurs clients avec un dernier
conseil on parlait des orages de la
capacité à récupérer les autres pluies
on peut remplir sa piscine avec de l'eau
de pluie absolument et d'ailleurs ça se
fait naturellement à partir du moment où
vous avez une couverture qui laisse
passer l'eau sur le côté si c'est
la piscine va se remplir naturellement
et si vous avez une cuve de récupération
de l'eau de pluie bien entendu vous
pouvez l'utiliser pour refaire les
appoints d'eau et c'est d'ailleurs un
des points qui est conseillé dans notre
flyer sur les usages de l'eau j'ai pas
le temps de tout vous détailler mais
néanmoins tous les conseils ils sont
donnés et si tout le monde s'y met je
pense que on arrivera à je me disais
quasiment encore moins doux dans les
piscines alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est 30
mètres 39 mètres cubes le remplissage
initial on a diminué de 45%
l'utilisation de l'eau entre les années
90 et aujourd'hui dans les piscines et
on est en train de faire encore mieux
grâce aux nouveaux équipements
l'automatisation la couverture l'abri
etc merci beaucoup Nicolas Garnier je
reviens vers vous sur ce ces
recommandations que vous avez
fait au gouvernement
vous l'avez dit le président il veut
nous faire faire 10% d'économie d'eau
d'ici 2030 vous dites qu'on peut aller
beaucoup plus vite et il faut un briquet
les collectivités locales territoriales
comment alors en fait l'idée c'est de
reprendre un peu ce qu'on a fait au
moment de la crise énergétique puisque
le gouvernement nous a demandé de faire
moins 10% de des économies d'énergie et
on s'est rendu compte pendant les 12
derniers mois que par des petits gestes
du quotidien et une reprise en main de
la consommation d'énergie on a obtenu
moins 13% en 12 mois et on s'est dit
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas faire la
même chose dans le domaine de l'eau et
donc on a proposé un plan de sobriété
municipales Dunkerque a mis en place de
la tarification incitative donc en fait
tout ce qu'on a proposé dans ce plan à
la fois et ça demande aussi une
mobilisation des agents municipaux des
maîtres d'écoles des des fonctionnaires
de la mairie peuvent devenir des
économesaux à la fois en créant ces
changements de transportement c'est tous
faites les sécher vous essayez de
baisser de 10% votre consommation vous
allez voir c'est assez facile en
particulier par des choses très simples
et donc ce dispositif permettra de
démontrer qu'on arrive à faire moins 10
beaucoup plus vite et l'idée c'est que
ça aspire le monde agricole le monde
industriel avec lequel on a des
dialogues et les collectivités sont
aussi capables d'accompagner le monde
agricole le monde industriel vers ces
économies c'est le plan qu'on propose à
tous les territoires français Nicolas
Garnier pardon nous interrompre mais
c'était passionnant et surtout ce qui
était bien c'est que ça nous permet de
terminer sur une note positive avec des
exemples de solutions qui existent déjà
qui sont mises en page et qu'on peut
dupliquer j'ai terminé avec vous
Frédéric denré avec une info qui moi m'a
à la fois pas surpris et beaucoup énervé
je suis fan de sport et notamment de
tennis Roland Garros ils quand je les
cours pendant trois semaines parce que
aussi les qualifications à l'eau potable
parce que il est fait comme ça parce que
pour une question d'économie de bassin
voilà c'est l'opoda oui c'est aberrant
aujourd'hui on pourrait réutiliser sans
doute de l'eau issue des stations
d'épurations de l'eau récupérer sur les
toitures de l'eau pluviale comme font
beaucoup d'industriels aujourd'hui comme
font beaucoup de communes ben oui pour
pas qu'on respire de la poussière en
regardant les jours de tennis on arrose
à l'eau potable on fait pipi dans l'eau
potable on lave nos vies
améliorer déjà notre système de
récupération de réutilisation des eaux
usées on est on est très très loin et
des autres pluies on est très très loin
derrière d'autres pays d'Europe merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
était passionnant on a entendu des
points de vue contrastés et j'espère
qu'on a avancé dans notre connaissance
de la gestion de l'eau et dans notre
capacité à la partager Frédéric je
rappelle le titre de votre livre
rencontre avec des écolos remarquables
livres qui est publié aux éditions de la
chaux et nièce les voilà merci encore je
vous dis à lundi merci à toutes et à
tous de votre fidélité vous pouvez
retrouver nos programmes évidemment sur
la plateforme Public Sénat point FR et
notez que demain on continuera de parler
sport sur notre antenne puisque dans la
matinale Oriane Mancini reçoit Christian
Prudhomme le directeur du Tour de France
voilà on va commencer à se projeter vers
les routes du Tour et ça sent bon l'été
donc en été oui il va falloir faire
attention allô merci beaucoup merci à
toutes et à tous de votre fidélité à
Manille
[Musique]